et le Golden Globe est attribué
à Christopher
[Applaudissements]
Nolan c'est la 6e nomination et la
première victoire pour Christopher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Nolan
merci merci merci au Golden
Globe la seule fois où j'ai été sur
scène auparavant c'était pour recevoir
ce prix au nom de notre cher ami slger
et ça c'était compliqué et difficile
pour moi et pendant mon discours j'ai
levé les yeux et Robert Dany Junior a
attiré mon œil et on a échangé un regard
d'amour et de soutien le même regard
qu'il échange avec moi le même amour et
soutien qu'il a apporté à tellement de
personnes dans notre communauté pendant
toutes ces années j'aurais pensé que ce
serait plus simple de recevoir un prix
pour moi-même et en tant que
réalisateur je ne peux accepter ce prix
qu'
n des personnes que l'on rassemble en
tant que cinéaste pour qu'il vous offre
leur meilleur Robert K mon complice
depuis 20
ans mat je sais pas où tu es allé et
Florence
Ilie vraiment le travail incroyable de
notre équipe technique
épousstouflante tellement de personnes à
remercier merci de conclure alors
allons-y don Lang chez
Universal vu le
potentiel dans un livre très difficile
Chuck qui m'a offert ce livre et qui m'a
poussé à continuer tellement d'autres
personnes à remercier Emma Thomas ma
partenaire à la ville et à l'écran merci
merci